hi Judy how are you hi I'm fine Dave
enjoy your show Thanks
how can I help okay we're in our 70s and
we violated our own rule about a year
ago and sold our house so that we could
buy a it was a paid for house we bought
into a condo retirement community which
we loved living in we have a 3% mortgage
and our note is only three hundred and
fifty eight dollars a month with an HOA
of 200 that is our only debt we owe
about 83 to 85 thousand on the house and
the equity is probably a hundred and
sixty five we have seventy five thousand
in savings and our gross income is
$52,000 a year my question is we never
had a house payment four years and now
we took this on in our old age would it
be smarter to pay off our mortgage or
pay it way down or hang on we feel we
have to hang on to some cash let me stop
you the only money you have to your
whole name is $75,000 in cash yeah I'm
talking about you have no other money
saved at all for retirement except
$75,000
that's correct you don't have a 401k we
do have to rock our IRAs but that's part
of it that would be oh it's part of
75,000 yes you have any money anywhere
of any kind
other than this 75,000 now on you Oh
eighty thousand yes so you can't pay it
off no we can't we we could pay it way
down and we could pay it off pretty
quickly but you'd be completely broke
that's right now I mean we need to keep
some assessable money yes you need to
you know if you don't if you're so broke
that you're 71 years old and all you
have to your whole name is $75,000 you
do not need to use your last dollar to
pay off the mortgage you're stuck with
it okay well we're not having any
trouble handling it I just I know we
know what is the fish what is the 50 mm
coming in from my husband has a city
pension
I have a real small pension and I also
draw a lo what happens when he dies
Social Security my pension will continue
to come to me at a hundred percent okay
all right well then you got fifty two
thousand to live on and bathroom for the
dollar payment until you die right we
are not sorry we moved here we just we
violated our own rule but we needed to
do it for health reasons and so we sold
our house at a loss and moved here but
we like it so is there anything smart we
can do other than just do what we're
doing I think you're stuck